Stell dir vor
es ist Fastnacht,
Fasching und Karneval,
und keiner geht hin.
Und jetzt stell dir vor,
du musst dir’s nicht vorstell’n,
denn es ist wahr,
weil die Dinge so sinn!
Es erklingt kein Alaaf
und auch kein Helau!
Aber es wär‘ doch gelacht,
Wenn der Karnevalist nicht trotzdem
das Beste draus macht!
Akkordeon
Keine Sitzung? Egal! Dann schunkeln wir halt
zu Haus im Feinrippunterhemd!
Der Vadder steigt im Bad in die Bütt,
die Mudder ist die Präsident - TIN!
Konfetti kommt per Email, der Tusch via App,
wir halten die Laune hoch und die Kurve flach,
das Dreigestirn sind diesmal Drosten, Streeck
und Karl Lauterbach!
Als Jungfrau mit ner Fliege!
Ole! Ole! Ne Fiesta – würd‘ mich zwar nicht stör’n!
Aber Regenwürmer will derzeit wohl keiner Husten hör’n!
Doch Viva Corona - eins ist wunderbar:
Am Aschermittwoch ist nix vorbei, weil gar nix war.
Man muss es beste drauß‘ machen,
denn dann merkt man glatt:
Auch ne coronöse Session
macht uns nicht platt!
Manches ist sogar besser:
In den Kneipen ist Platz,
und kein Einhorn pinkelt ans Eck,
Und wenn man ehrlich ist:
Die Umstellung ist gar nicht so groß,
ne Maske trägt er eh schon, der Jeck!
Auch ne Polonaise auf Abstand kann schön sein,
Der Erwin lässt die Heidi in Ruh!
Und mancher kleine Feigling
lötet sich mit Desinfektionsmittel zu.
Aber das knallt leider nicht!
Ne, ne, ne das ist keine superjeile Zick
Wenn das hier vorbei ist
blickt keiner gern zurück!
Et gitt kei Wood, dat sage künnt
wie beschissen ich Covid 19 so find.
Doch es hilft alles nix
Wut, Zorn und Zeterei!
Heile, heile Gänsje, es ist bald vorbei!
Ei, Ei, Ei!
Mer losse dat Virus inne Maske,
denn do jehöt et hin.
Wat sull dat dann woanders,
dat hät doch keine Senn.
Echte Fründe stonn zusamme,
stonn zusamme mit nem Meter 50 Platz!
Die Karawane hält Abstand, de Sultan will dorsch,
de Sultan willl durch, de Sultan will durch!
Liebe Coroniken und liebe Coronäsen,
isch wünschte mit der Pandemie,
wär‘s dess schon gewese,
Doch es ist zu früh, um den Frohsinn abzuwinke,
mer kann auch online via Zoom,
gemeinsam Schoppe trinke.
Und‘s wird aach widder besser
des weiss ich ganz genau,
Bleibt fröhlich unn fidel:
Tschüss, Alaaf, Macht’s gut! Helau!